hey guys and welcome to another episode
of my 1gp to 1 mil flipping series I
really enjoyed doing the last one and
you guys did as well um so for this next
challenge I'm going to just be doing it
again just with different items now in
the future I would like to do it with
certain restrictions or challenges or
whatnot uh but I just kind of felt like
doing it again because it was really fun
it's just the thrill of starting from 1
GP finding that item is honestly the
hardest part uh but anyway I'm glad you
guys enjoyed it and let's start uh once
again okay so we have 1 GP and uh we're
going to do totally different items this
time now to start off this is always the
most lengthy part when I wanted to do
this I'm like okay well I'll just find
the first item two hours later I'm still
looking but anyway we found a item that
may work and that is the monkey nuts as
you can see it actually drops down to 1
GP uh looks like four or five times in
the last uh 24 hours and surprisingly
they actually trade quite a bit um so
we're going to give that a shot uh we'll
put an offer in for the monkey nuts only
have one GP uh this is a random item I'm
not actually sure what is
for try for 1 GP and uh yeah well
hopefully we'll buy it and we'll be back
in a minute okay so we bought the monkey
nut and uh really didn't take very long
cuz you can see uh the amount traded is
actually about uh 15 to 20 uh every half
an hour uh which is extremely good for
this type of item uh now we bought it
for 1 GP and we're hoping to sell it
for 279 I just popping in for
275 uh and this should sell really quick
honestly assuming we have the right
price and all uh this should sell in
like 10 minutes or something because of
how many are traded really going to have
to try this item more CU I don't think
it' be a 1gp very frequently and yeah
very good start all right not bad 1gp to
275 a really nice start didn't take very
long at all uh so now we're definitely
going to go back and buy more of those
uh you can see 1 GP 275 that's not a bad
margin I would say so myself uh we're
going to increase it by 1 GP and we'll
go
for we'll go for 50 we're going to be
gone for a while today uh so it'll be
100 coins invested in the monkey nuts
and um the next item I wanted to try was
actually the monkey bones I can see here
it does occasionally drop down to 3 GP
not sure if that's going to stay like
that or not but we'll give it a try
we're going to get a work
we'll try putting it in for 10 GP for
the monkey bones uh for any of you whove
been around a long time this is the
first item I did in pretty much my first
ever Series so it has a little bit of a
sentimental value I guess and uh yeah
we'll do fif well 17 of
these and yeah hopefully the monkey
items can carry us out of this early
start well that was extremely quick I
haven't even left for work yet uh we'
gotten four of the monkey bones so far
but all of them the monkey nuts have
come through at 2 GP each uh which is
exceedingly good uh going to flip those
for
275 uh which will get us a
13.7k profit off of the an item when I
had no money that is extremely good uh
monkey bones we got four of them so far
and we're hoping to sell them
for 500 GP well some for
475 and they are coming through quite a
bit slower but still still coming
through uh not a bad profit all right so
the monkey nuts have all sold off very
quickly I might add monkey bones not so
much uh we didn't end up buying any more
of those so we're just going to pull
that out and uh we did sell some of the
monkey bones that's good 1.5k there uh
but the monkey nuts we did sell for
13.7k that is awesome so to start off
we're going to go ahead and just buy
well let's just go check monkey nuts
again cuz it's been a while since we
actually put an offer in
uh we bought one for
$279 and can we buy it for very cheap
again one coin all right we're going to
go ahead and buy a bunch more of these
just because of how quickly they come in
we're going to go for a thousand we're
going to leave that in for a long time
well let's do 500 we let's see how many
are traded a day actually uh cuz we're
going to be gone all day at work again
uh let's go back to the monkey nut go
back to the month uh actually actually
about a th000 traded a day we'll go
ahead and do a th000 shoot for the moon
here and that would be an extremely good
margin on that so next up we have G
Tracker open with the highest margin
page once again uh we filtered the items
down to under 10,000 and added uh
removed any buying quantity filter as
well uh so now we're looking at some of
the items here now Steed body T looks
kind of
interesting uh maybe have a look at that
mythal full lmg uh also is a free play
item I've done a lot uh got the crosier
red robe top that looks kind of
interesting uh we already had it open
here um now it doesn't trade a whole lot
but we could put an offer in for one or
two of these because it looks like it
has a great margin uh when it does sell
goes as low as 100 up to 10 100,000 oh
my God uh we'll try buying a red R top
for 600 how about red robe
top we'll try we'll do 701 and we'll go
for five of those next up the studed
body T looks like it's buying for about
3K and selling for 9k uh so I think
we'll use the rest of our money here
studded body T put it in for 301 and do
three of these that's going to use up
pretty much all our money there and uh
looks good all right we'll be back after
work all right guys we are back and uh
we got three of these studed bodies
which is awesome uh red robe tops four
of
those and it looks like 192 of the
monkey nuts but most of them bought
before I went to work I think the price
have changed already uh so we'll go
ahead and recheck the monkey
nut just because it's not too
expensive 279
still not bad so we'll sell us off
for a 50k profit which is extremely good
uh next up we want to do the studed
bodies uh now see I don't think I have
them open anymore uh so studed actually
I wanted to have a look at this item
after oh it's right here my bad uh
reload page and we got the red robe top
here as well okay so we're going to try
selling these studed uh bodies
for
9k so that would be a nice well we're
selling them for yeah it'll be about 20K
profit on that the red R tops go for a
huge varying amount of price uh but
we'll go for
4799 uh which is going to be a nice
profit on its own and yeah so we'll come
back when these have sold all right guys
so we're back and uh We've sold
everything off the red Rob tops for
4,800 not bad 20K from that stead body
te's always sold for 9k each 26k from
that and the monkey nuts uh for 53k
profit pretty well uh so 100K we have to
work with now uh so I found a couple of
items uh that are now on the highest
margin page uh we're looking at the Rune
halberg uh mainly because it trades so
much uh it's a pretty popular item and
it looks like it actually has a really
good margin buying it for 44k and
selling it for
63 uh and there's yeah like 1,000 traded
a day so this really W won't take very
long to flip these I will buy two of
them for go for
46k all right R halberg for 46k and we
can just avord two of those once again
the monkey Nets are still buying for
just one GP each so I think we'll put
another offer in just because uh the
only thing that would have a good enough
margin to actually just leave a bit of
money in for uh we'll put offer in for
we'll put it in for five how about and
do 1,000 all right we'll come back when
the Run halberg have flipped okay the
Run halberg actually flipped very
quickly uh we sold them for 128k and
bought them for uh 92k so as a 36k
profit definitely go back and just buy
another one of those can I get
three not quite just do another two and
come back with hopefully another 32k
profit okay another excellent margin on
the Run halberg uh we sold them for 69k
each and two of them so 138k on that uh
we had a quick look at GT tracker again
and while there are
a couple other items on the highest
margin page the Rune HG still at the top
uh so we'll probably just continue on
with that uh the gr Shield looks kind of
promising but 37k to
49k that's pretty good but I don't think
that's as good as the Run halberg uh so
we're going to continue to buy these
because they do buy very quickly uh 46k
and now we can
buy almost four but we'll just go for
three well maybe we could just pull
these nuts out we're not buying very
many 5K plus that would be
185 I still don't think we'll have
enough we'll just leave it in there for
now and buy another
three all right so the Run how bgs have
come in 69k they sell very quickly take
a little bit longer to buy unfortunately
but that's okay 27k and we bought them
all for 138k so it is a 70k profit very
good I'm certain I could flip these all
the way to a mill but to mix it up we're
going to add in a couple other items
starting off with the samurai shirt
which we're going to buy for probably
around 181k looking to get a 30k profit
on that
roughly uh it's just worse but that's
okay just for the sake of interest uh
making this kind of interesting Samurai
shirt was it Y and we're going to buy it
for
181k and next up I found the gothic
cloak uh this looks actually a little
more promising buy it for about 42k and
sell it for 62 Maybe
and uh it's a pretty cheap item and does
sell and buy pretty quickly so Gothic
cloak going to buy you for
42k and that's not going to leave us
with much money left over and we'll come
back hopefully when these have flipped
so apparently the gothics cloak does
flip a little bit quicker than the
samurai shirt already totally flipped it
for 54k and if you recall we bought it
for
42 uh so a 16 12K profit there sorry
and on the samurai shirt we just bought
it so far we had to bump it up to
183k now we'll try to sell it back
for
um I guess 215 is what it was at on GT
tracker so
214k uh which is actually going to be a
pretty good profit of about 20 about 30k
and we got another 76k so we'll buy
another one of those cloaks cuz they are
flipping pretty quick and uh I want to
have enough money to buy some more
halberg but we got some monkey nuts
coming through 122 of them and we'll
just recheck the margin
here looks like we're going to sell them
for only a 100 each interesting uh we'll
leave that in there for a bit longer cuz
it was at 200 before so it's possible
just a quick dip and uh yeah we'll come
back when uh these items have flipped
all right so we did finally sell off the
samurai shirt for a 30k profit not bad
and the gothic cloak as well for 54k uh
which is good as well uh so it's going
to leave us with about 300K cash and the
monkey Nets have not sold uh so I don't
know what's going on with them probably
the price has not risen up again yet uh
so I think we're going to go ahead and
buy another one of these Samurai
shirts and I think we're going to buy
another one of the Run halberg uh it's
been a while but I such a good margin
before we'll just go and buy two of
these if we have a look at the dragon
Square Shield ornament kit it look looks
like it has a crazy margin 16k into
67 uh so we're going to go ahead and buy
one of those Dragon Square Shield
ornament
kit
Dragon Square
Shield ornament kit uh for an extremely
cheap price
of
17K
nice and yeah that's what we'll do the
rest of our money and we'll come back in
a little while all right so we manag to
buy the Dragon Square Shield we're
hoping to sell it for
67k uh hopefully that'll happen soon
monkey Nets are coming through at 200
each there we go sold most them off and
we just have 14 more whatever and the
samurai should have uh flipped for a 30k
Prof on that run halberg have not come
through so we're just going to pull that
out and I'll probably look for another
item because we do have 300K so we're
going to come over with the G tracker
and just bump up the filter once again
to 300K uh so now we'll have uh
hopefully some different items have a
look
at all right Dragon Square Shield is
still at the top interesting uh gothics
Dragonite Set uh not a whole lot trade
per hour Dragon chain body ornament kit
interesting uh once again another
ornament kit see how many of these trade
per day all right looks like it's down
to
130 uh and could sell for actually 160 H
very good margin on that we'll give that
a try Dragon chain body ornament
kit dragon chain
body ornament kit going to buy it for
132k and we can afford two of those and
last up we're going to try buying some
ballista limbs in hopes of selling them
for cuz these seem like occasionally
they sell for about 50k each so we'll
try buying them for about 33k each uh
ballista limbs buy them for 33k and we
can just afford two of those and we'll
be back hopefully when some of the stuff
is sold all right all right we're back
with some good news we got a lot of
stuff sold uh the dragon Square Shield
sold for a massive margin
67k uh took a long time but
uh is it on there
anywhere the hell is it okay 21k is what
we bought it for not bad uh the
dragon oh those are still coming through
sorry the ballista limbs we did sell for
49k uh those are come through for quite
a while uh but still a really good
margin on them 40 or we sold them for 98
came bought him for 66
let's go ahead and buy some more of
those right away and we'll go up to four
because they did buy and sell pretty
quickly honestly and we do have a dragon
chain body ornament kit coming in for
about a 20K profit on that uh that's
going to leave us with 200k I don't
think I'm going to do this again because
they don't uh buy and sell that quickly
and the margin isn't that great all
right interestingly enough the dragon
Square Shield still up there uh we have
the cannon barrels and Cannon furnace
which we might do but we don't have a
lot of money so we're definitely going
to put another offering for the Dragon
and square Shield uh just because of how
lucrative the margin is uh we'll just
put in for 21k for now uh so that going
to leave us with enough money to do
another item here Canon furnace is
192k don't quite have enough for that
what about the gothics Dragon headset
152k into 177 that's pretty
good
Gothic Dragon HDE set going to buy it
for 153k which is pretty good and also
looks like we
have um well we got the dragon Square
Shield coming through already that is
great that off for
67k in that case I think we'll buy
another one cuz we actually do have
enough money for that and it
is a very good margin 21k buy another
one of those and we got a Ballista limbs
coming in so looking good and we'll come
back in a couple hours all right so we
got everything to sell except for the
other Dragon Square Shield or or kit we
got one of them to sell which is good um
but we'll start on the left Dragon chain
body ornament kits sold for 312 and we
bought them
for uh 264 so that is a 40K profit on
that pretty good uh the ballista limbs
uh sold for 49k each or 196k in total uh
giving us a 60k profit there even better
uh the dragon Square Shield orament kit
once again we sold uh for 67k giv us 45k
roughly on that
really extremely good for the price and
the gothic dragon head set sold for
176 and that's going to leave us with a
26k profit on that uh did trade very
quickly though so that leaves us with
600k uh we're getting very close once we
sell off this last bit here that' be
667k uh so we're like 2/3 of the way
there so let's have a quick look at G
tracker uh so now we have up to 600k
we'll fill up to double our current cash
stack and see what items it spits out
all right so not much has changed
actually the dragon Square Shield is
still there surprised I hasn't sold yet
but the the cannon barrel and the cannon
furnace are on here um now the problem
with this is I'm not sure how many
people are actually going to buy the
individual Cannon Barrel cuz usually you
either lose your entire Cannon or you
just yeah that's probably not going to
be that good I don't think we're going
to do that all right I think we'll try
the dragon plate skirt ornament kit try
buying it for
350 um not actually a very good margin
but we'll do it anyway so we're going to
buy it for
351k and just do one of those going to
leave us with
249k now for the items I just did what
would be the best ones uh we could do
the ballista
limbs uh or I think we'll do
the gothics Dragonite set for 153k uh
that did trade prettyy quickly anything
we can do for
96k uh ballista limbs for
sure we'll do some more ballista limbs
hopefully we can buy a couple more of
those uh go for
three uh Perfect all right we'll be back
not perfect never mind uh it's some bad
math okay we'll just do two I guess all
right unfortunately uh the Bliss limbs
didn't end up selling for anything
higher so we end up dumping them uh the
dragon Square Shield we're still kind of
hoping to sell for a bit of a profit but
anyway uh we didn't lose very much on
that Gothic Dragonite set made another
20K off of that and the uh dragon legs
SL ornament kit uh 383 and we bought it
for 351 not bad but it did take a long
time I don't think we're going to do any
of those items again uh now look at this
black dide body G going from 86k to
21 that is just insane we're going to
definitely have to try one of those
black deide body
G um how frequently is this going to
trade not bad actually uh so we'll try
buying it for uh 9
87K and H we'll just we'll just do one
of those for now um the other item I had
open here was the royal scepter again
just an insane margin I don't really
know if that one dip down to 40K I don't
think we'll get it for 40K uh but if we
look at we look what the [__] a mint
cake all right um we look at the goat
tuber uh trades a decent amount 43k on
it is a decent margin uh we'll try
buying it
for 558 I know people do need this so
when they want it they'll just buy it uh
558 and we'll try selling it for around
600k and uh yeah looks good we'll come
back in a couple hours when these things
have
sold I'm assuming that nobody's ever
realized this but the Scout tuber looked
exactly like the monkey nut I almost got
lost in there unfortunately but we did
sell it for
5.98k uh which is a 50k profit pretty
well uh well 45 or something like that
uh dragon Square Shield we ended up
dumping cuz it wasn't selling and
excitingly we did get the black di body
uh which we are going to try to flip for
a crazy profit of
195k that is going to be an extremely
good margin I would say uh but a 100K
profit on a item that only cost me 87K
we're going to go back and buy another
one of these for sure cuz actually
bought well took a couple hours but it
wasn't that slow and we'll go back and
buy another [__] not don't quite have
enough for another goat tuber uh we have
a look at the highest margin page we
could go
for let's try the cannon Barrel base uh
for 186 I don't think we're gonna sell
it for that huge a margin at saying
because that looks a little bit
ridiculous but we can still flip a
couple of these uh Cannon
barrel and try buy it for
186k and we'll go
for well I guess two of those all right
looks like we can't get a perfect amount
and we'll be back in a little while all
right so we actually sold the black de
body for 195k that is
crazy and uh the cannon base we sold for
222 uh these did take quite a while to
tell uh we don't have another one coming
through yet so I'm not really
sure maybe well let's go have a look at
G tracker all right I think we're going
to do another goat tuber for
561 um was a pretty quick flip well not
that quick but and maybe another Cannon
Barrel base while it's not the quickest
flip it is a very good margin 186 and I
guess somebody does kind of need a
cannon base every once in a while and uh
I don't know if we should continue to
try to to buy the black
deide we'll we'll leave it in there
since I don't think I have another item
really to
buy and yeah I think that's probably
good and hope maybe if we're lucky
that'll be all we need to finish off the
mill all right so we actually did manage
to flip another black dad uh body for
extremely good profit of 100K uh didn't
really expect that one to come through
but it did Cannon Barrel we had to
reduceed stand the 202 H not bad and the
go tuber for 598 is that going to be
enough oh it just is barely going to be
enough uh looks like go tuber we got 30k
on uh Cannon Barrel set we got about 20K
I guess and uh the black TI just an
extremely good margin we'll sell off
these dumb monkey nuts now uh we don't
need these things anymore and that's
going to be it guys so I hope you
enjoyed 14
GP uh that's going to be it I hope you
guys enjoyed the 1gp to one mil
challenge if you have any suggestions
for uh ways I could kind of modify this
in the future I know a lot of people
want me to do a free-to-play version uh
which I am working on but [__] takes
a long time uh cuz clearly free to play
is not nearly as good it's probably take
three times as long as this uh as you
might realize in my first series I did
this and it was an eight part uh freeto
playay to bond series um so yeah it's
going to take a while but I will get
that out eventually any other ideas
though uh please leave a comment uh with
your suggestions all right hope you
enjoyed and I'll see you guys in the
next next video
[Music]